in the last video we talked about
titrations and p i-- or isoelectric
point in this video what i want to talk
about is peptides and dot that i
peptides polypeptides and peptide bonds
to sort of wrap up our discussion or our
introduction of or our introduction to
amino acids peptide bonds so we
mentioned before that amino acids are
the monomers for proteins right so amino
acids essentially are the building
blocks for proteins right they make up
proteins so what are proteins right well
if they're a bunch there they're
essentially right at the bare minimum
they are a chain of amino acids right so
there are this is a long chain of amino
acids but it is a little bit more than
that long chain of amino acids but for
now this this is sort of okay it's a
longitude of amino acids right but
specifically as a function of some sort
okay so as with a particular function
okay so oops function amino acids
essentially make up proteins so how do
they do this right how do amino acids
how do we get a bunch of amino acid to
come together bond together to form
these long chains that we avenge that
eventually have some sort of function um
you know they become proteins so we're
going to answer that question right how
how does this happen
how okay so first and foremost what I'm
going to do is talk a little bit about
um just things to keep in mind when when
thinking about all this so the first the
first idea that we need to be familiar
with is
a peptide bond right because these amino
acids need to connect to each other
right
so we route peptide bonds okay what is a
peptide bond a peptide bond is the amide
or a maid a maid bond connecting the
alpha carboxyl group of one of back that
up for just a second carboxyl group of
one amino acid right to the Alpha amino
group of another amino acid right so the
simplest term right to describe a
peptide bond it's simply the covalent
bond that connects one amino acid to
another but specifically it can net the
connection point is between the carboxyl
group of one amino acid right to the
amino group of another right both of
them being of course the Alpha carboxyl
group in the Alpha amino group okay so
now within peptides anyway when we talk
about peptide bond people always talk
about you know what is a peptide or does
it die peptide tripeptide so let me just
briefly run over that that idea
so if we're talking about a peptide
right we're talking about a short chain
of amino acids okay so that's
essentially what a peptide is if you
have just I don't know let's say you
have 10 amino acids connected to each
other right all of course being joined
together by peptide bonds you can call
that a peptide now you can get more
specific a dipeptide
would be two amino acids long right a
tripeptide would be three amino acids
long and I'm sure you get the point
right here okay the whole idea is that a
peptide is not really a particular
amount of short a short chain of amino
acids if you have a longer chain you can
call it a polypeptide right if you have
many high poly means many right so
pelmeni peptide and many many peptide
bonds say a long chain of amino acids
okay so now what's the difference
between a polypeptide and a protein
right the difference we'll get into this
more specifically later when we start
talking about protein structure but the
just as a brief introduction the
difference between a polypeptide and a
protein is that a polypeptide is simply
a long chain of amino acids these long
chains end up folding upon themselves in
some way once they do they typically
have a particular biological function
when they have that biological function
at that point they're considered
proteins okay so again more on that
later hopefully when we get to the
protein structure videos okay so let's
talk about how this sort of looks right
so just just writing down words isn't
always too helpful but let's let's bring
up an example let's try to draw a this
let's see how a peptide bond actually
even forms okay so by convention right
by convention we sort of talk about
peptides as being we write them from
left to right okay with the amino group
first okay so the convention is is left
to right right left to right the left
being the alpha the Alpha amino group
right and then the right being the Alpha
carboxyl group right so this is often
called the amino terminus so the the
left end
of a peptide or a polypeptide would be
the amino terminus and the Alpha
carboxyl group the would be the carboxyl
or carboxy terminus carboxy or carboxyl
terminus okay so now what I mean by this
whole convention why why did I even say
this let's do a quick example let's say
we want to draw draw the dipeptide right
and it'll be written like this oops
let's say they want us to draw this okay
this is a dipeptide okay because there
are two amino acids this one being
Albany if you remember the three-letter
code this being cysteine right so what
we want to do is we want to draw how we
want to draw the dipeptide okay so let
me actually just fill this in here draw
the dipeptide right right and let's say
it's at a pH of seven okay
so well first what we're going to do is
simply draw out each amino acid just as
you know just themselves okay so how
does alanine look well alanine looks
like this we're going to draw both amino
acids at the way they would look at a pH
of seven okay so alanine would look I'm
actually draw it a little bit lower to
save some space okay so alanine would
look like this would have it to me a
group here right l alanine of course at
this point we're talking specifically
about L amino acids the side chain for
alanine is just a methyl group now
instead of drawing it just you know as a
Co Oh minus up here I'm actually going
to draw out the the entire group the way
it would look at a pH of seven okay so
this here is alanine okay
now the reason why I do this is because
if alanine right is the first amino acid
and this amino terminus is here that
means the amino terminus of alanine is
not going to be included Titebond it's
going to be connected at its carboxy
terminus which is why I actually drew it
out here so I could show you how it is
that the bond actually forms so cysteine
right is going to be right next to it on
this side so I'm just going to draw like
this right and it's amino terminus right
is going to be the one involved with the
bond all right so that's the amino group
the Alpha amino group alpha hydrogen and
then cysteine as ch2 and it's the one
that's one of the sulfur containing
amino acids right so it's it's going to
have the carboxy terminus so that's also
going to be involved in the long okay so
what's going to go on here we have to
connect these two amino acids together
how does that happen well the simplest
way to look at it is that we have this
kind of go down what am I doing here
these atoms come together and leave now
what do they just circle here I circled
two hydrogen's in the water now you guys
probably know that that is two
hydrogen's in all water I'm a fool
excuse me two hydrogen's and an oxygen
which makes up water right so this is
actually going to when these two
functional groups connect to each other
they're going to connect by a via ID
hydration synthesis reaction right so be
a dehydration synthesis right otherwise
known as a condensation reaction
condensation reaction okay now some
people might be thinking wait what does
hydrolysis the hydrolysis is a little
bit different hydrolysis is the addition
of water to a bond to break that bond so
I can actually show you a little bit
about what that sort of means in just a
moment here so what happens is we're
going to go down we're going to go ahead
and lose water in this process right so
we're going to lose water and what
going to end up happening what's going
to happen is that this car box this
carbon here from the carboxylate
carboxylic acid group on alanine is
going to become covalently bound to this
nitrogen here so just to keep it as
simple as possible the way I'm going to
draw this Fischer projection dipeptide
is like this you can move it down just a
little bit alright so right come down
here and the way it's going to look it's
a little bit like this right so let me
just draw this uh just like this
actually that's that's a little bit off
sorry about that
okay let me ask draw like this so we
still nothing happened to the amino
group on alanine nothing happen at the R
group they're not involved in the bond
this hydrogen is not involved carbon
here this carbonyl group is not involved
what happens though is that this carbon
is going to connect to this nitrogen so
this nitrogen right you lost two of its
hydrogen's I fractured all the positive
charge on it
sorry about that so now it's going to
have a hydrogen here and it's going to
have two electrons hanging around okay
now the rest of the amino acid stays the
same right the carboxyl group up here
and the hydrogen the R group they all
stay the same so what happened is we
created this covalent bond here which I
will highlight with in blue okay so this
here this bond is the peptide bond okay
that is the peptide bond now it formed
via dehydration synthesis right we lost
water right so I can write this here and
we lost water or you can write it here
as plus water so like this so it during
via this reaction we created that
covalent bond and we made water so we
the dehydration said this is also a
condensation reaction if you're familiar
with the idea of condensation is just
when it's just like the forming of water
essentially when we're talking about
going from a gas to a liquid in the case
this is the bonneville created now if we
wanted to break this bond that would be
a hydrolysis reaction we have to use
this
attach it to this bond and then cause
the the formation of these two
individual amino acids again okay so now
what we did in here we've done here is
we've drawn this dipeptide at a pH of
seven okay
if we had a for instance if we had our
groups that had specific PK's that we
wouldn't necessarily be familiar with
we'd be provided with those P P K's so
now you could be expected to to draw
this depth at a different pH maybe at
one or three or ten who knows right you
would have to be provided with you have
to know the P K's of the all the
different ionizable groups now notice
that this group here right on alanine
the carboxyl group prior to the
formation of this peptide bond
it was ionizable but now once once the
prep type bond is formed this group is
no longer ionizable right the alpha
amino group still is and this carboxyl
terminus is but there's no you can now
is the scrip here what we've created
here now is this amide bond and the
reason why it's an amador a name ID is
that we have a carbonyl group here and
then none of that carbon isn't is a
nitrogen so that if you think remember
back to organic chemistry that's that's
what that's an amide functional group
which is not ionizable okay so this is
essentially at this this dipeptide that
we've drawn here is this here we've
drawn we've drawn it just as a it's it's
as it's written here now I do want to
sort of talk a little bit about this
peptide bond and mention one quick point
one quick thing about it now um if you
notice if you notice we've got here let
me actually just draw it in a different
color let's do white
so what I want to talk about is how
you'll notice that here right this this
carbonyl group here this carbon is what
we remember as sp2 hybridized right
the angle is between these these bonds
are each 120 now what can happen right
because of this this electron pair being
one bond away from this double from this
double bond
this electron-pair candy localized and
we can have a residence form so that
leads to this what I'm going to actually
talk about here so let me just think
about everything that's bound to just
this carbon and this nitrogen because
those are the two atoms that are like
involved with this resonance I mean they
did you play over with the other atoms
but I kind of want to just draw
everything that's connected to this
carbon and to this nitrogen so let's
call this club this alpha carbon right
carbon alpha number one and let's call
this carbon alpha number two because
this carbon is connected to this oxygen
here and this carbon here so that's one
two three four five six atoms that are
all connected right to this carbon in
this nitrogen here so let's let's kind
of visualize that so the carbon you move
this down a little bit need some more
space okay so if we have this carbonyl
group here right in this alpha carbon
number one right and we have this
nitrogen here and the Alpha carbon up
here the second one and then we have a
hydrogen here okay with those electrons
there so now those are the six atoms
that are involved here now I mentioned
right that this can be localized so
notice well the reason why I mentioned
that this this these bond angles were
each 120 is that that means that
everything that's bound to this carbon
right is in the same plane right so this
oxygen this carbon this carbon and this
nitrogen are all in the same plane and
especially because of this resonance
this resonating effect right because we
have a resonance form this can also end
up being sp2 hybridized so we'd have
this going on oops getting ahead of
myself withdrawing that alpha alpha
carbon okay so what we have here now as
we form that double bond there this
nitrogen here
and the second alpha carbon up here now
this carbon or this nitrogen will have a
positive charge is all should one have a
negative charge overall charge stays the
same but now notice that this this
nitrogen is now sp2 hybridized
everything in the in that plane is also
what's called in the same plane so now
all six of these atoms can be in the
same plane so so why is that why is that
significant the reason why is this that
that what that leads to is this
important idea it's important idea that
that rotation about this peptide bond
rotation about the peptide bond is
restricted right because it's flat all
those six of those atoms are in the same
plane okay so bear that in mind
that that has an effect on protein
structure we've talked about a one
particular idea about how prolene
prolene is the only amino acid that has
an R group that comes back it connects
to its amino group that also has an
effect on the wave you know steric
hindrance that that has an effect on the
way proteins can can sort of Bend and
fold so this is sort of the same idea
here except this applies between every
peptide bond or two every peptide bond
so that kind of wraps up our discussion
of amino acids this is how you draw
peptides this is a little bit that you
should know about about you know what
what about the peptide bond that it's a
covalent bond that is that the
restriction of rotation occurs
essentially like I've mentioned before
this is how you draw a dipeptide if you
wanted to draw a tripeptide or even
longer peptide they would just you know
you would just have more amino acids to
connect nothing too crazy but each one
would would release one water
so I hope that was a helpful sort of
description of what goes on with
peptides polypeptides and peptide bonds
and I'll see you in the next video